[Musica]
ci crediamo ed è cambiato il mondo
svegliamoci il mondo è cambiato
svegliamoci e cambiamo il mondo sono tre
frasi che usano esattamente le stesse
parole con significati e toni molto
diversi
le parole sono il risveglio ovviamente
qui il mondo e il suo cambiamento io
voglio parlarvi di cambiamento non siamo
abituati al cambiamento siamo adatti al
cambiamento non siamo dati al
cambiamento come organismi viventi
tendiamo l'equilibrio qualsiasi cosa che
modifichi il nostro stato chief a
dissipare energia per raggiungere di
nuovo un equilibrio come operatori
economici
siamo facciamo il nostro destino e
quello di manipolare i fattori
produttivi per ottenere un tornaconto
ogni modifica dei fattori produttivi del
contesto è un guaio ci costringe a
lavorare convincere delle persone
riportarci l'equilibrio e forse ri
otterremo un tornaconto
e poi siamo europee italiane mantovani
viviamo in uno dei territori dove si
vive meglio al mondo
se il povero steve jobs fosse qui e si
guardasse non direbbe sky fango io non
sicuramente penso ne ha penso neanche
voi senso neanche voi quindi non è
quella la molla che ci porta al
cambiamento
ma di che cambiamento parliamo parliamo
ci sono due autori friedman e a un
giornalista americano di quelli che
vanno in giro intervistare le persone
che contano per il mondo e tenere la
persona che al budget di ricerca più
grande del mondo è il detentore del
budget di ricerca di
google sono concordi che esiste un
livello molto alto del cambiamento che
loro chiamano il cambiamento di alta
quota che ha caratterizzato da tre linee
parallele del discorso la prima linea e
naturale se chiama cambiamento climatico
e ho sentito la pioggia poco fa il
secondo la seconda linea cambiamento
sociale
si chiama la globalizzazione delle
persone dopo la globalizzazione delle
merci
stiamo attraversando la fase di
un'accelerata globalizzazione dell'emea
delle persone ci sono in questo momento
350 milioni di persone che si stanno
muovendo dal luogo in cui sono nato sono
cresciute ce ne rendiamo poco conto
forse perché il 92 per cento si muove
all'interno dello stesso continente
eppure la terza linea di cambiamento e
il cambiamento tecnologico la legge di
moore sono 18 20 anni che ogni due anni
raddoppiamo la nostra capacità di
processare dati abbiamo una capacità una
velocità di processare i dati
enormemente più alta di quella che
riusciamo ad utilizzare questi dicevamo
però sono i cambiamenti di alta quota ma
vicino a noi e sulla pelle dove sentiamo
le gocce d'acqua dove sentiamo freddo
c'è un altro tipo di cambiamento e la
prima o fattore di questo cambiamento
potremmo dire che la velocità la
velocità importantissima perché ci
stiamo rendendo conto che se andiamo più
veloce di quello che la velocità ci
chiede cifra cassiano commettiamo errori
con più facilità
non ce la facciamo più ad andare più
veloci di come stiamo andando
e molto probabile che la risposta alla
velocità sia la continuità continuità un
fattore che ci costringe a
riorganizzarci completamente a cambiare
i nostri sette mentali e organizzativi
quotidiani ea lungo termine
cerchiamo di capirci meglio quando siete
in un hotel e aprite rubinetto
dell'acqua calda
arriva subito l'acqua calda a casa mia
con il boiler a 9 metri ci mette un po
più tempo perché perché in un hotel o in
un luogo pubblico di quel tipo esiste un
circuito di a
che tiene continuamente in movimento
l'acqua calda per cui l'acqua calda
scorre a pochi centimetri da rubinetto e
quando lo aprite risponde ecco provate a
immaginare la vostra organizzazione la
vostra vita come se tenessimo
continuamente in movimento questo
sistema per esempio lo sa bene chi deve
fare innovazione
se tu comincia a fare ricerca nel
momento in cui il mercato ti chiede una
risposta un prodotto un servizio non ce
la fai non ce la fai nessuno tira più il
tempo di fare quello che hai bisogno di
fare nessuno non c'è più il tempo o sei
già in movimento o ti sei fatto le
domande quando nessuno ti faceva le
domande
oppure se dal marketing arriva
l'iniziativa vuol dire che qualcuno tra
i tuoi clienti ha già visto un qualche
cosa ha fatto da qualcun altro è troppo
tardi
la seconda caratteristica importante e
l'autorialità l'autorialità perché noi
siamo abituati siamo cresciuti in un
mondo in cui si dà un grandissimo valore
al genio individuale genio individuale
l'uomo della provvidenza
le soluzioni arrivano perché qualcuno a
un certo punto ci pensa ed è dotato per
risolverlo quando sappiamo
scientificamente che l'intelligenza
collettiva è enormemente più potente di
qualsiasi singolo genio e il terzo
elemento è legato alla noni limitatezza
delle risorse siamo nati e cresciuti
parlo per la mia generazione soprattutto
abbiamo visto il filmato precedente
pensando che tutto quanto sarà a nostra
disposizione per semplici troviamo a
lavorare invece in un circuito in un
sistema in cui tutti gli output tutto
quello che noi
scartiamo deve essere rimesso dentro un
altro sistema come input non deve
diventare un input economia circolare
chiamatela come volete sistan design
anche questo ci cambia nettamente quadro
in cui operiamo
e poi siamo cresciuti in una situazione
in cui sapere sono blindati si dice il
silos
no io mi occupo di un settore guai se
invado il settore del vicino ma pensata
in un'azienda le chiamiamo divisioni più
chiaro di così libia dita e abbiamo dato
anche il nome giusto per cui sapete che
uno non parla con l'altro e se parla non
parlano la stessa lingua non si
capiscono
ecco noi scopriamo che le cose più
interessanti arrivano da degli ultimi
tempi dal crossing tra più saperi le
neuroscienze le biotecnologie sono
sempre situazioni in cui ci si incontra
e ci si scambia o si guardano i fenomeni
con più punti di vista
e poi il prodotto prodotto noi siamo un
permettetemi il made in italia cultura
di prodotto noi sappiamo valutare al
tatto al fiuto al sapore al gusto alla
vista anche da distante la qualità delle
cose abbiamo rispetto alla media globale
una cultura del prodotto molto alta
peccato che è il momento in cui ha molta
importanza alla qualità del processo la
qualità del processo diventate
importantissima ce ne siamo accorti
c'è un canale 52 che qualcuno di voi son
convinto che guarda io lo guardo che
trasmette trasmette come si produce la
marmellata come si fanno gli pneumatici
cose di questo tipo pensate che un
broadcasting americano tradotto in 27
lingue lo guardano 850 milioni di
persone al mondo per almeno quattro ore
alla settimana saranno di tutta questa
cultura sulla fabbricazione degli
pneumatici
eppure una passione no io ho visto una
trasmissione due anni fa in cui a report
mostravano come si scappava il piumino
delle oche le oche non felici che non
donavano volontariamente questo più o
meno il giorno dopo la borsa di new york
questa impresa terzo 180 milioni di euro
di dollari di capitalizzazione
ho passato la mia prima parte della mia
vita con mia mamma che mi diceva compra
lo controlla
so che ci sia più o meno è la seconda
parte della mia vita con mia moglie dice
seria c'è il pazzo se è un maiale è
comperato una roba con dentro più o meno
no no non so più cosa comperare
e poi le questioni materiali le cose
materiali e noi siamo cresciuti nel
materiale
siamo in un mondo in cui ci occupiamo
delle cose materiali perché abbiamo un
corpo ci occupiamo delle cose digitali
eppure ci troviamo a vivere lavorare in
un mondo che si è accorto che tutto ciò
che è materiale deve avere un gemello
digitale se no non esiste ma tutto ciò
che ha digitale deve avere un gemello
materiale il gemello materiale
fondamentale lo sa ma john che era forse
l'unico operatore economico mondiale che
poteva fare a meno di comparire sulla
scena e sta cercando di aprire negozi
fisici in tutto il mondo non è
fondamentale abbiamo un corpo se tu stai
nel digitale e non compare ai nostri
sensi non esisti
e poi ancora la privacy la privacy
stanno spiando state state attenti
state attenti eravamo convinti che le
nostre cose le sapevamo forse noi e
qualche amico non le nostre cose sono di
dominio mondiale di dominio globale
fanno tutti tranne che noi forse no e
quindi immaginate in un mondo in cui
l'informazione il bene principale le
nostre informazioni le sanno tutti o le
usano quelli che vogliono
ecco questo cambiamento è impetuoso a
che fare con la nostra capacità di
affrontarlo e con la nostra capacità di
gestire una cosa che chiamiamo
anticipazione sono le futuro chance sono
tanti studiosi da molte discipline
diverse che da diversi decenni studiano
il futuro come se fosse un fenomeno
scientifico e alcune indicazioni cell e
possono dare
andiamo molto velocemente la prima
informazione che ci danno forse la
sapevamo il futuro non si può prevedere
dicono si può costruire
interessante la seconda informazione che
ci danno e che il futuro del futuro noi
conosciamo delle porzioni no
immaginatevi una torta alcune fette noi
le poste di a una fetta si chiamano
costanti se l'uomo sulla terra diciamo
da un punto di vista cognitivo da
250.000 anni e si comporta in certi modi
da 250.000 anni
questo significa che probabilmente
domani non so cosa dovrebbe succedere
per modificare il nostro comportamento
quindi attraverso lo studio delle
costanti se ne occupa l'antropologia noi
abbiamo delle porzioni di certezza poi
abbiamo dati quantitativi su ogni cosa
demografia clima tutto tutto tutto dal
1500 negli archivi parrocchiali del
mondo cristiano c'è scritto il nome dei
nati quando sono nati quando sono morti
o sono sposati quando sono battezzati
eccetera eccetera
immaginatevi che moli di dati abbiamo e
ci permettono di fare delle curve di
avere una ambizione di prospettiva
poi abbiamo i dati qualitativi dei trend
della moda vive di trend e sappiamo che
colorando al prossimo anno
sapete quest'anno e coral no l'anno
prossimo lo sappiamo già e quindi
immaginate di quanti dati abbiamo sia
qualitativi sia quantitativi e poi
abbiamo i latenti che una parola un po
difficile per noi la chiamavamo nel
nostro mondo il mondo del design della
moda la chiamavamo i segnali deboli
segnali deboli sono qualcosa che già nel
presente ma è portatore di futuro
immaginatevi che il tempo sia questa
cosa qua questo è il passato e questo è
il futuro
noi siamo nel presente lo tagliamo qua
cos'è il presente presente alla
permanenza di alcuni elementi del
passato
le tele mie dita che si rimpiccioliscono
e l'inizio di alcuni fattori che fanno
già parte del futuro e quindi studiando
e togliendo gli elementi del passato ci
rimane una porzione di futuro e se lo
analizziamo rispetto alla dinamica che
sta avendo la diffusione
ma come cresce ci possono possiamo già
avere in mano degli elementi che ci
permettono di studiare il futuro e poi
ci dicono ancora quelli delle foto
censis che il futuro
singolare non esiste esistono i futuri i
futuri sono tanti sono in competizione
per succedere quindi noi dobbiamo
lavorare di scenari stica per capire
come adattarci ai vari futuri che
potrebbero succedere e per esempio poi
ci dice che il futuro un fatto
collettivo collettivo quante più persone
noi riusciamo a convincere che quel
futuro che auspicabile per noi sarà
ospitabile anche per loro e quanto più è
probabile che quel futuro si avveri lo
sanno un bambino che vuole andare allo
stadio cominciamo a rubare il padre lo
zio poi la madre la sorella la cugina
della cognata quante più persone riesce
a coinvolgere quanto più è probabile che
verrà portato allo stadio e quindi il
futuro ricordiamo c'è un fatto
collettivo e poi il futuro inizia nel
presente quindi l'azione che commettiamo
oggi è una porzione importante di quello
che succederà domani
abbiamo visto anche con la carta
igienica e poi il futuro contiene
diciamo degli atteggiamenti noi abbiamo
degli atteggiamenti rispetto al futuro
sono quattro il primo atteggiamento in
cui noi italiani siamo bravissimi più
grandi del mondo
stiamo atteggiamento urgente è già
successo un patatrac un qualche cosa
forza tutti a lei a corriamo a mettere
un riparo la cosa no
la famosa dezza penso che proprio
l'abbiamo inventata noi restiamo il
brevetto della pezza saremmo ricchissimi
poi c'è un secondo atteggiamento che si
chiama emergente vuol dire che stanno
succedendo alcuni elementi seri teniamo
sotto controllo sono portatori di
qualcosa che sta succedendo e quindi
cominciamo a intervenire
il terzo comportamento si chiama pre
attivo non sta succedendo niente ma
qualcosa succederà e quindi io comincio
a prefigurare messi di chi si chiamano
proprio scenari
degli scenari e a studiare come posso
comportarmi nell'ipotesi che qualcuno di
questi scenari si avverino
e posso farlo sia per contrastarli che
per farli succedere se mi sono propizi
il quarto atteggiamento si chiama
proattivo ed è proprio l'azione del
mettere energia dell'investire affinché
quelli propizi si avverino quelli in un
propizi non si avveri
e poi un altro ultimo elemento su cui
diciamo la futurologia e futuro shawn
heins l'anticipazione ci portano a
riflettere e che è molto importante per
riuscire a lavorare sul domani e che di
solito il tempo che ci interessano non e
domani domani inteso proprio nel domani
il 26
ma il domani nel mondo del marketing e
l'anno prossimo la prossima collezione
la prossima stagione il prodotto che
porterò in fiera le vacanze che devo
organizzare per capire se il domani è
giusto io devo studiare il dopodomani
perché il dopodomani che mi dà la
direzione della se una persona di
incontravi dice sfondando giusto dovete
come minimo chiederli dipende dove vuoi
arrivare no e quindi le parole
profetiche di due grandi italiani che
erano totò e peppino che dicevano
volevan sour noio volevam savuar per
andare dove dobbiamo andare dove
dobbiamo andare contenevano già in
essere questa profezia cioè se non se
non sappiamo dove dobbiamo andare come
facciamo a scegliere la strada per
arrivarci
grazie della vostra attenzione
[Applauso]